while America's combat mission in
Afghanistan may be over our commitment
to Afghanistan and its people endorse
many people in the United States and
many in partner countries that have
sacrificed so much to have a simple
question what is our purpose in
Afghanistan after so many years they
asked why do our men and women still
fight and die there by the end of 2014
the Afghans will be fully responsible
for the security of their country this
year we will bring America's longest war
to a responsible end
I know that many of you have grown weary
of this conflict as you are well aware I
do not support the idea of endless war
you